good morning relief nation today's
message is follow your intuitive nature
over to you Phil Jackson who is it Indy
Jones it was in one of his Indiana Jones
one of his films Stephen boots Gilbert's
guy you know was asked what are we going
to do next and he says I don't know I'm
just going by feel here and that's
that's kind of the way it is at times
that you have to follow your intuitive
nature you don't learn leadership skills
of Iping from other people I've gotten a
lot of books sent to me about leadership
I think management is as a you know
loads of books about leadership that
people read and they have you can pick
up ideas from those but if you're not
affinity or who you really are people
see through that pretty quickly you
never have the perfect information to
make a decision this is one of the
challenges of leadership you will never
have complete 100% information to make
an important decision because by the
time you get 100% the opportunity will
pass the solution would have already
come and likely from somebody else
somebody else is chasing down that
opportunity and prove that it works
where if you don't jump on it and prove
it yourself you're going to lose every
time
how do you make that decision when
you're only 65 75 85 percent confidence
but listen to you intuition you really
know what is the right thing to do both
from a human perspective of what's right
for you so that you don't live with your
bread that this is something that has to
come up and with more experience and
more practice of following your
intuition you realize what is right to
the market what people want what is
likely to work out or not you know when
I make a new video for this channel I
have an intuitive sense of if it's going
to be really good or not if I really
really deep down feel like this is
insanely amazing I haven't had many of
those videos flop and it comes from
experience and the more you hone in on
listening to your intuition the better
you're going to get as a leader and as
an entrepreneur
let me tell you quick story about Alex
who helps me run trying to dance salsa
he desperately wanted to be a better
leader when he first joined me last year
one of the things he had to work through
was he was afraid of confrontation
anytime there was a difficult decision
potential confrontation he would run
away he would delay he wouldn't write
back to you he would avoid the situation
and by recognizing that this was
something that he wanted to get better
at and he was holding himself back
subconsciously we slowly worked on him
getting better when there was an issue
that came up he had to convince himself
by thinking it through that the behavior
I'm doing is not rational it's not what
I want to do it's not of my own
self-interest it's not in the interest
of the other people for sure but it's
not what I want to be doing it so after
thinking it through for an hour he would
get to the point where he would take
action on it recognizing that was just a
fear that he had and he slowly got
better at it in that one hour you know
became 45 minutes became half an hour
between 15 minutes and slowly got to the
point where when there was a difficult
situation he would want to deal with it
he would still be afraid but he want to
deal with it but it wasn't instinctive
yet his instinct was to run away and we
all had these things yeah we all have
these these fears insecurities with the
instinct is to run away to not address
it to not deal with it
Tellis is instinct but because he builds
a muscle and it was in his own best
interest of what he wanted to do what
how he saw himself as a leader it got
more and more and more intuitive and
more instinctive for him to the point
where last week at his condo
there was a fight that happened
downstairs two guys broke out into a
fight and nobody was doing anything and
now it's not on him to do anything you
know security guards right there they're
not doing anything nobody wanted to be a
leader and step up and the test of a
real leader is when there was a vacuum
of leadership when there is no
leadership a leader steps in and fills
the void and so Alex didn't take an hour
to think about it he jumped in and he
stopped the fight he did what the best
version of himself would do and it was
an instinct he managed to take the thing
that he was not good at it was the
opposite of he would run away from every
situation that was potentially
conflict in it to the point where it
became something that he thought about
and slowly fixed to the point where now
it's his instinct and his habit to jump
in and solve the problem with experience
of understanding where you are limiting
yourself what behaviors you are doing
that are holding yourself back and with
repeated effort and practice to build
the muscle through practice through
dedication through continuance you can
get to the point where that behavior
that you wanted to change that you would
run away from now becomes an instinctive
reaction to do the right thing
the more you follow your intuition and
lean in on it the more you practice
doing the thing that the best version of
you wants to do then the closer you will
close the gap for yourself and make the
right decisions and have the biggest
impact that you can so the question of
activity is I'm curious what was the
last instinctive decision that you made
that turned out really well for you
where you didn't have complete
information but you made a gut check and
it worked
let me know leave it down the comments
below I'm super curious if I know I also
want to give a quick shout out to Lemke
sit thank you so much for picking up a
couple of my book your one-word I really
really appreciate the support I hope
you're learning from the book and you're
applying it to your life and to your
business thank you guys again for
watching I hope you have an amazing day
I believe in you and hope you continue
to believe in yourself and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events better
[Music]
well I love college because I knew
exactly what I wanted to do and some of
you know too but some of you don't or
maybe you thought you knew but are now
questioning that choice maybe you're
sitting there trying to figure out how
to tell your parents that you want to be
a doctor and not a comedy writer well
what you choose to do next is what we
call in the movies the character
defining moment now these are moments
you version while you're with like in
the last star wars the force awakens
when ray realizes the force is with her
or Indiana Jones choosing mission over
fear by jumping into a pile of snakes
now in a two-hour movie you get a
handful of character defining moments
but in real life you face them everyday
life is one straw a strong long string
of character defining moments and I was
lucky that at 18 I knew what I exactly
wanted to do but I didn't know who I was
I could I and how could any of us
because for the first 25 years of our
lives we are trained to listen to voices
that are not our own parents and
professors fill our heads with wisdom
and information and then employers and
mentors take their place and explain how
this world really works and usually
these voices of authority makes sense
but sometimes doubt starts to creep into
our heads and into our hearts and even
when we think that's not quite how I see
the world it's kind of easier just to
nod in agreement and go along and for a
while I let that going along to find my
character because I was repressing my
own point of view because like about
Nilsson song everybody was talking at me
so I couldn't hear the echoes of my mind
and at first
the internal voice I needed to listen to
was hardly audible and it was hardly
noticeable kind of like me in high
school but then I started paying more
attention and my intuition kicked in and
I want to be clear that your intuition
is different from your conscience they
work in tandem but here's the
distinction your conscience shelves
here's what you should do while your
intuition whispers here's what you could
do listen to that voice that tells you
what you could do nothing will define
your character more than that because
once I turned to my intuition and I
tuned into it I certain projects began
to pull me into them and others I turned
away from now why did you decide to come
out with roar like there was that big
countdown and then roar came out and it
was huge for you like him he broke your
own records there why was it roar the
first single um you know it was up to up
for debate a couple of singles it was
going to be roar another one and we
decided to go with roar because of the
reaction I was getting from my friends I
kind of like use my friends as guinea
pigs as test guinea pigs and I have a
very eclectic group of friends ranging
from you know DJ's to artists to just
moms and they all really agreed that
roar was the best one and you know it
has that bouncy feel the eighth-note
feel but it also has this message of
finding your inner strength again and
letting that kind of come out as a roar
and people related to it yeah well they
really did and there's something yeah
there's something like there's an
intuitive thing that happens inside of
me and I've always trust my intuition
when it comes to writing songs and
picking which song should come out as
singles you fall in love with somebody
here you don't love him here what
happens you get a stomach ache here
where do you follow love with your
stomach
are you cultivating your intuition and I
would say if you're not drinking enough
beer at the Oasis you're not taking
advantage of your education because what
you're going to do in life is you're
always going to be gauging people if
their BSS or not if you're not
cultivating your human skills they're
going to slow you you know I mean
drinking beer is not your enemy drink a
beer and socializing having coffee
you're learning that those are very
constructive moments you're learning is
that a person a BS are going to trust
them what is the behavior that I really
want for my workers